welcome everybody to dc
thursday i'm pete soderling i'm the
founder of
data council in the data community fund
and i am pleased
to be your guide through the crazy vast
sprawling data ecosystem
and as you know we bring you amazing
guests
every week people who are influential in
the world of data data engineering data
science analytics
ai research etc and today we have an
amazing guest
for you no exception i'm
extremely pleased to welcome raghu
murthy to the show raghu is
the founder and ceo of data coral prior
to that
he's worked at some amazing companies he
was eir at social capital
he's been a pmc member for apache hive
an engineering leader at bebop which was
acquired by google
an engineering manager at facebook and
also an engineer
at yahoo ragu also has a masters in
computer science
from stanford so ragu that's uh quite
the
list of accomplishments um welcome to
the show
well thank you so much for having me
pete it's great to be here
so um i've been looking forward to this
conversation for a couple weeks because
um you're another one of these unique
people who's sort of seen data
from the very early days back back in
the days when we called it
big data forgive the air quotes but
it seems like we've come a long way uh
you know in the last 15 or so years
and you've you've seen a lot of it so i
want to start at the beginning
um how did you how did you get
interested in data
um originally like what was the what are
some of the circumstances surrounding
your early jobs with data
yeah happy to share i'll be definitely
dating myself so i started at yahoo
back in the year 2000 almost 21 years
ago now
and the main reason for me to join yahoo
back then was to just work on systems
so i didn't have much of a background in
databases or anything like that i was
actually more into compilers back then
and at yahoo the goal was to process
large amounts of data by writing unix
programs
because trying to load that data into
oracle and like process the data there
was way too expensive
so from there we kind of graduated to
building a sql parser that would
essentially generate the configuration
for these unix programs
and the goal was to run these unix
programs on multiple machines that all
had
a a single nfs uh
mounted netapp filer with all the data
so it was kind of this duct taped
glued together system that actually did
pretty well
uh we had i think close to 100 terabytes
of data
you know around 2006 or so
2007 and that's
kind of how i got started into data
didn't really know much about databases
i actually
went to grad school after i was at yahoo
and that's when i realized that
what how parallel databases were built
and turns out we had actually solved
some of the same problems
uh in very similar ways so it's just
being a software engineer and a systems
designer and uh you end up solving these
problems
so that was my start and and when did
the hive emerge on the scene um
at yahoo uh so
hive actually started off at facebook
right so i joined
facebook in 2008 and they were just
about getting started working on hive
so this time around the problem was
similar
process large amounts of data because
oracle was
too expensive try to find an alternative
and this time around the alternative was
hadoop so
at facebook people had gotten started
already on working
on hadoop and then realized that writing
these map reduce programs was kind of
hard
so they were writing a sql parser that
would essentially generate these
map-reduced jobs
by the specifications for the map-reduce
jobs
and i joined the initial team that built
an open source type at facebook
and yeah so when i joined facebook they
had
uh as you can imagine a smaller amount
of data than yahoo
so i think facebook was at 50 terabytes
or so about half of what
yahoo was back okay
but yeah so clearly at facebook
dramatically
and uh over a period of about five years
it went to like hundreds of petabytes of
data
across multiple data centers and so on
so that was a
kind of a different trajectory than what
i'd seen with yahoo
gotta and so i forget where were you
working on hadoop
at yahoo and did that sort of inform
your hybrid no you weren't
you weren't in the team yeah yeah so i
was working on data before it was called
big data i guess so
so there's like a separate team that had
gotten started on hadoop
but i was in the data team
working on this this kind of unix-based
data processing kind of systems and
hadoop
i think was started more on the search
team
at yahoo got it well then
um since since you ended up at facebook
and that and that was
um sort of the the introduction to the
hive experience
talk to us a little bit about how hive
was used at facebook and
some lessons that you learned over those
years
yeah so the great thing about the way i
was built at
facebook was the general
kind of movement towards democratizing
data right so
trying to get pretty much every part of
the company to be able to leverage data
and not build these or not have these
kind of centralized teams that were
in some sense kind of controlling access
to the data and because that was the
traditional kind of way of doing things
uh back then so kind of called it like
the priest model
right so to get to guard your data you
have to go through the priest
right but the democratization of data
meant that
there were now these systems and tools
that are available for everybody in the
company
to be able to do whatever they wanted to
do with the data it was an open system
there were no uh restrictions or
constraints on what people could do with
their own data
so there was of course kind of security
around sensitive data and so on
it might be hard to believe but even
back then at
facebook uh people were worried about
kind of the sensitive data that was
uh sitting in uh the data systems and
very few people could access
for example uh like the payment kind of
information and stuff like that it was
all kind of
uh hardened off but this general
movement to have
everybody in the company to become data
aware was
the the impetus for hive and pretty much
every layer
that we built on top of hive to
including ways to build data pipelines
to
be able to kind of ingest data without
having to write too much code
being able to build dashboards all of
that stuff was built
by a central team but pretty much
every product team every engineer knew
how to interface with the data without
really having to
jump through too many hoops got it
um and where where was facebook ad in
its data data infrastructure um when you
ended up leaving
so i left the data team in 2013 so over
a period of five years
i went from 50 terabytes to probably
like
150 or 200 petabytes of managed storage
across multiple data centers
uh in fact the last project that i did
at uh
in the data team was to make it so that
data could actually sit in multiple data
centers so we had one giant hadoop
cluster and we
keep running out of space and we had to
keep moving these clusters from one data
center to another
and we reached a point where we
did not build a data center big enough
to hold all the data
so we had to kind of mid uh flight like
you couldn't just shut down the cluster
right so
we had to we did this kind of intense
project
that made it so that we could actually
split data
and move it into different data centers
and different group clusters but of
course people had gotten used to joining
data from different kinds of
sources so we built like a pretty
efficient kind of replication
and kind of like a subscription model
for not
small amount like terabytes of data so
people would subscribe to
certain tables and there there'd be like
petabytes of data moving between data
centers
uh because support analytics that would
then happen in those clusters in those
data centers
so that allowed us to kind of get to
quote unquote infinite scale i'm sure
the past i guess eight years or so
they would have gone to much more
sophisticated systems but
uh that evolution for me and being part
of it and
being kind of so closely
and associated with it was really cool
yeah that's uh that's great um and it
obviously inspired you to
build some new systems for the world
yourself that you that you thought the
world needed and so
um you're one of the few engineers i
know who became an eir
so i'm kind of curious to to learn about
that i guess i guess bebop was sort of
probably sandwiched in there
somewhere um but ultimately you you
became an eir
um so i'm really curious to hear like
how that transition happened and
what the motivation was yeah so
after bebop uh i spent about a year
there
um i was just kind of sitting at home
and the folks at
uh social capital uh who i'd worked with
in the past at facebook
uh they just told me if i was interested
in just learning about what is happening
and essentially treat social capital as
like a parking lot
for whatever i wanted to do next
and uh they said eir and
i told them like look i don't have any
ambition to start a company yet so i'm
not really an entrepreneur
uh so then they said okay
it's engineering there's an instance so
still eir
but that's kind of how
[Music]
um and so so what tell us a little bit
about that experience like what what did
you
do on a daily basis and um what were you
interested in at the time and
um i i mean i think i know kind of where
the story ended
um but uh i i curious to hear like
how what was sort of transpired what's
transpired in your mind as you were
trying to figure out what an engineer in
residence was supposed to do
yeah so my goal there was to just drink
from the fire hose
right so social capital had incredible
people
and some amazing companies coming in
talking to them
and i was just amazed
by all the different things i mean the
thing about social capital was that
they were looking at all kinds of uh
verticals as well right like frontier
technologies or like
uh healthcare or enterprise
like all over the place and one common
theme was the fact that
everybody had data that they wanted to
work with
and they knew what they wanted to do
with the data
but then they were kind of
figuring out how best to kind of do that
and turns out
everybody had to hire engineers to
leverage their data
so i grew up in my career having built
all the systems that we used right these
companies like yahoo and facebook they
had
immense resources to invest in engineers
like
us to be able to build all the systems
because there's nothing out there
and the more i talk to these companies
these are fairly small companies they're
uh they were really successful companies
but they're
probably not even hitting this they
never hit the scale
of like a facebook in their entire
lifetime even though they became really
big
and this is also around the same time
that
really the clouds were becoming more
popular and specifically
serverless technologies were becoming
popular
and my take was that
because there were the clouds and all of
these serverless technologies the
complexity of building a system or
building
a a data infrastructure stack had to be
like much lower than the complexity that
we had to deal with
both because there were primitives that
the clouds offered and the fact that
the data volumes were not that high
and the more that i started pulling on
that thread the more i realized that
specifically with serverless
technologies it might be possible
to build quote-unquote a
push-button data infrastructure stack
where
you don't really need engineering to set
things up
you can have an analyst or a data
scientist who would be able to kind of
fend for themselves as long as the new
sql
it should be possible or there to be a
a product that would help them
kind of do their job without really
having to deal with the underlying
systems or even the plumbing of the
pipelines that were needed so
that kind of got me thinking about and
what it takes to kind of build
this kind of a system and the first
thing that i did about it is not
actually make a deck or anything i
started writing code
and some of social capitals portfolio
companies
who i was talking to i was telling them
that i was building this and they said
that if i built it they would use it
and the idea and the idea was basically
to take the engineering
out of data engineering um so to speak
yeah engineering the complexity of
engineering out of
uh data in general right so i had seen
so many of these companies that had data
scientists or data analysts
who were you know basically stuck
writing scripts and
uh kind of pipelines and they wanted to
analyze data
but then instead they were maintaining
these pipelines
and that was taking up so much of their
time that their
analytics kind of productivity kind of
was decreasing
so yeah so when i said that i was going
to build something like this
some of these companies said they would
use it and then
i definitely have to blame the folks at
social capital
uh who said hey looks like there's a
company here here's a check
i was like okay i'm i'm just building
this uh because i think something like
this should exist
but that is kind of what caused me to i
guess start the company
wow but uh yeah it's been an amazing
journey
so that became the obviously the company
became
data coral and um and now you have many
more customers and you've been
building serverless oriented cloud-based
data infrastructure
for the last few years yep that's great
yeah that's great um and what was the
response from the early customers like
i'm curious as to um
you know is there a learning or a lesson
or a story from some of the early
customer days that
you can share with our audience
yeah so in the early days
most companies they started off saying
that if i have to get serious with data
i need data engineers and in fact we did
talk to
a few companies who had data scientists
who had built out these kind of
pipelines
who who basically told me yeah i think
i've got it covered
uh i don't think i need a product that
will solve this problem for me
but then six months later they kind of
came back and
said well uh maybe we don't uh we need
something uh
that will actually ease this pain of
having to maintain data pipelines
and we don't really have a budget or we
wouldn't uh want to spend our
precious engineering resources on this
so is there
something that uh you could do to
uh you know for us to skip the
uh the step of first hiring an engineer
who would then go and build stuff
right so that was we saw this
happen quite a bit with a lot of uh you
know the initial companies that we
talked to
and then as we started uh providing
our own product and our product matured
we started
finding that people in these companies
could actually
grow their data teams with mostly data
analysts and data scientists
and they would have maybe data engineers
that would come in
uh mostly to uh avoid some of the
tooling that
uh some of these teams needed for their
kind of ci cd pipelines and whatnot
but for the data processing itself uh
many of these companies were able to
just rely on our
product and our you know the data
integrations the data transformation the
integrated data transformations as well
uh to build like uh pretty sophisticated
pipelines that
um that they would otherwise have to
spend quite a bit of engineering on so
the
you know the most heartening thing for
me to hear is
when uh the data teams say that they're
able to punch above their weight level
uh in terms of supporting multiple
business units are multiple um kind of
departments
with like a really small team because
they don't have to worry about
kind of building and managing data
pipelines
well i feel like you know from having
known you for the last three years and
watching data
data coral and the product evolve i feel
like
you were very early again um not
surprisingly
um in this sort of modern etl
pipeline stack because i think
you were talking about ingest and
transform
and these kinds of terms it feels like
before they became industry standard
like i don't know exactly when five
trans started and dbt probably started
in 2017 or so
but i kind of feel like you had
pioneered
um some of these terms if not the terms
themselves at least the concepts in your
early plumbing um that you had built in
the building blocks that became
data coral talk to us a little bit about
how you saw the
the sort of design patterns and what
some of the key principles were of the
of the data coral system so
when i got started uh there were a few
data integration companies i mean of
course you had the traditional companies
like informatica and so on i mean
they've been
around forever my take was
to make kind of two things one is
the fact that uh being cloud native
means that you can move a lot faster and
you can actually
help companies that are cloud native as
well so if companies were born in the
cloud
they don't want to use any of these kind
of traditional kind of systems that are
much more fully featured and so on
so there are kind of two parts to
how i was thinking about both uh
what we are building in terms of the
system as well as the
the terms that we are talking about
right the notion of kind of in just
transformed and published is kind of
what we uh called it
um and in fact we called transforms
materialized views because that is what
we had generalized the concept around
so the two parts were one
building a system that's cloud native
that's serverless
that would allow for the software to
actually be deployed in the
end customer vpc so the software would
be deployed in the cloud
so this would be not a multi-tenant sas
kind of offering that was kind of
the norm but instead the software would
be running in the customer's cloud which
meant that
data would never leave their control so
that was one of the big
things for me and i'll kind of get more
uh talk more about
data security in a little bit so that
was the serverless part and then the
the other part was on the data flow
itself like the the in just transform
and publish
so this is just based on my experience
having built
these systems in the past right so there
is typically only three things that
you're trying to do
uh with your data you're moving it or
you're transforming it it doesn't matter
how complicated your transformations
were it's still
you know you're uh you're you might be
running sql queries to transform it you
might be even
doing building machine learning models
you might be
making inference calls all of that are
essentially data transformations
and those became our primitives as well
like in terms of the data flow there was
the ingest
there was a transform or what we call
materialized views
and then there was the publish and i
guess nowadays publish
is being called reverse etl those
that's kind of the newer term that's
been happening probably in the past year
or so
so yeah so that's kind of how uh i
started kind of thinking about
data called it had to be end-to-end and
it had to provide these capabilities
so there's the serverless implementation
and then in terms of providing this
end-to-end capabilities
it was about having a metadata first
approach to building the uh
the data flow kind of primitives
so if you have these tools that
are doing their own orchestration and
have their own metadata that are
performing
different parts uh different
parts of your data flow and trying to
stitch them together work with them
dework problems becomes really hard
so again this was something that
i kind of experienced in the past having
seen the uh the challenges of
systems getting really complicated if
you have too many moving parts
without like the central brain if you
will
uh so we started with that we said okay
we are going to go metadata first
and then that also allowed our
data flow functionality of in just
transformer publish
to become a lot more lightweight and
that ties into
those kind of primitives becoming
serverless as well
right so because serverless typically is
meant at least at that point
was meant for like pretty lightweight
operations
so my take was how do we marry the two
the metadata first
architecture and serverless
and that uh that was a thread that we
have been i guess pulling
uh over the years and uh
we've been able to show that it is
actually possible and we have
in fact the way i look at it is we have
a reference implementation clearly there
will be multiple
uh kind of iterations on top of it that
we'll be working on and
i hope you know the industry also kind
of looks at uh
seriously as well and so
was was the serverless architectural
decision design decision
um was that well received by customers
at the time or was
most of that just hidden sort of in the
background and it was just your sort of
implementation decision did that have
material impact on
on customers interest in the product
because it was sort of very early and
serverless as well
yes so people didn't really care about
serverless but they did care about the
fact that the software was deployed in
their vpc
the fact that data was not leaving their
environment
so companies that would otherwise decide
to build something in-house because they
didn't
they didn't want to use a sas service
and
pipe their data through those systems
so those folks ended up
being attracted to our architecture
because
we could it's not just through
compliance that we were telling them
that hey your data is secure
we are able to prove to them that the
data is not leaving their environment
and that their data is encrypted using
their keys
so that means that even though we were
able to provide a managed service so
they didn't have to do any of the
monitoring or anything like that right
we were able to provide
uh you know slas on the data itself
uh the data freshness and so on we could
prove to them that we couldn't see their
data
so that was kind of the uh
the thing that attracted uh some of our
early customers
who didn't really understand the the
serverless part of it
yeah got it um you all and you also
mentioned metadata uh
obviously metadata is becoming kind of a
hot topic
today um right what what
manifestation did your metadata
architecture take was this something
that you
rolled your own did you use some any
open source
tools or how did you sort of run the
metadata management
piece of the product yeah so nowadays
metadata as a as a concept or
as kind of the thing in the industry has
kind of become fairly popular and as uh
his scope has increased it's kind of how
i put it
our focus on metadata has been
about operational metadata and
that means it's about having your
orchestration
be driven by your metadata rather than
by
uh people writing code or programs right
and
i'm happy to kind of get into a little
bit of detail on that
in terms of uh when you say what is
metadata first
um the idea is that
if each component of your data flow is
publishing information uh it's of course
kind of moving data or transforming data
but it is also updating a centralized
kind of metadata layer
and in addition to that you have your
orchestration
that is driven by that metadata so what
that means
is that let's say there is
a connector that is pulling data from a
data source and writing to a data
warehouse
it is not only writing data to the
metadata to the warehouse
but it is also publishing an event into
or publishing
uh to the metadata layer uh an event
that says hey uh let's say this batch
processing
here is a batch of data that got updated
in
uh in the warehouse now
if orchestration has to rely on that
event to trigger something downstream
what you need is a data dependency uh
kind of graph or the dag
right so we made it so that the metadata
the operational metadata included the
data dependencies as well
so what that means is that when
a new batch of data got written to
a data warehouse the orchestration would
then figure out
what is downstream of that particular
batch of data that just came in
and because the orchestration did the
dependency management it could then
trigger the transformations
for example when all the input data for
a particular transformation was
updated there was no explicit
orchestration that needed to have been
built out using a tool like airflow or
something like that
instead people would just write a sql
query
right that query would get compiled and
the metadata would now have the data
dependency so this query which is a
transformation
depends on these tables
and that's just the prompt clause of a
sql query
[Music]
and once you have that information in
your metadata
now the orchestration is essentially
doing a reverse lookup if you will
so every time a table gets updated
it figures out what are the
transformations that are dependent on
that particular
table and then each transformation has
multiple dependencies
so once all the dependencies are met
then the transformation can get
triggered
so you have this really lightweight
event driven
orchestration where even the
orchestration
engine itself or like the or uh the
orchestration itself can be serverless
right because it is only operating on
like a small uh like local area of the
tag
it doesn't have to actually load the
entire
memory or like keep it around or
whatever it the orchestration itself is
serverless it's even driven
there's an event that comes up
orchestration comes in figures out what
should run
regards them each of those things that
it triggers are also serverless
but then once it triggers and the
orchestration goes away
whatever runs does its thing emits an
event which then triggers orchestration
again
so that just simplified dramatically
simplifies the entire architecture
yeah and it also makes it um sort of
ready to go on a server-less
infrastructure which
is not something that many data
engineers have ever explored before
right exactly and one last thing i'll
add about this is that
because the orchestration is dependent
on these data dependencies
you are now forced to keep the metadata
clean
right so this is operational metadata
now
so that means that by design
the metadata that you can then view like
people talk about kind of the data
observability or like being able to
have like a single pane of glass for all
of your data flows and so on
instead of single pane of glass being
something that is accumulating
information from multiple tools and
trying to
somehow glom them together because there
are impedance mismatches between
different tools
here the shared metadata layer offers
like a
just looking at that metadata is already
a single pane of glass for your entire
data
right so that the metadata quality as
such
is not an afterthought it is actually
built into the system
yeah i love it um that's a that's a
super fascinating design
um i want to ask you about change data
capture because
i know that that's something that you've
also gotten interested in
recently um and and obviously
um fits into the the data coral
ecosystem
which uh i want you to tell us about um
but before we talk about the technical
um ins and outs uh talk to me about how
you got
excited about change data capture um and
the customer conversations you had that
sort of
made you aware that it was it was a need
i'm just curious
how that came to the surface yeah so for
the first couple of years that we were
in business we were just focused on this
kind of end-to-end flow
uh we were building in data integrations
which were pulling data from different
sources like databases or apis and file
systems and so on
and then we are also kind of doing the
transformation and the published site
too
some of our customers said hey we like
your sql based
connectors that are running sql queries
in the source database and
are able to kind of integrate that data
into your data warehouse
but we want to be able to handle
uh hard deletes efficiently so one of
the challenges with like a sequel based
connector
is that when you run a query on a table
to say give me all the rows that change
since the last time i uh i ran this
query
then if you're doing soft deletes it's
fine in an application
but if you're doing hard deletes that
means the rows go away the rows right
there
yeah exactly so now your sql based
kind of query
doesn't know that the row went away
right so now you have your data
warehouse that keeps accumulating all of
these deleted rows
because there's nothing that said that
a row was deleted now there are
ways to of course solve this problem
which is if the table has
primary keys then every so often you
fetch all the primary keys of
a offer table you don't fetch the entire
data but you fetch only the primary keys
and then you do like a join on the
destination
to then on remove all the rows where the
primary keys didn't
show right but as you can imagine it's a
fairly expensive operation
and in fact some of our early customers
did that
but then when these deletes became kind
of
uh or handling these hard deletes became
expensive they're like okay
there is thing called cdc that we have
known about
but we never really worked on because we
already had enough things to do
so so that became one of the
requirements and then the second thing
that came about was
people wanted to know uh exactly how
their data had changed
so if you have a sql based connector you
would
run queries every so often and you would
get the updated rows
but between your two fetches if a single
row had been updated like 10 times
you have no visibility into all of those
changes
you only get kind of like this snapshot
right so you get
time one and time uh 10. so all the
changes between time 1 and time 10
are lost so again doing
a log base cdc became important because
of that
so databases have uh this thing called
as a
right ahead log which is part of their
their own kind of replication mechanisms
or dr or
disaster recovery kind of mechanisms and
cdc connectors were essentially a way to
read these change logs or the write
ahead logs
from the databases and then apply those
logs into
the destination warehouse and
we found that there were a bunch of
advantages to doing this um
one it's a lot less expensive
to just read the write ahead log from
the database instead of
actually running queries on the database
right because
with running queries there's more load
on the database we had figured out a way
to
reduce the load by paginating and stuff
like that but
definitely a log based cdc approach
would be a lot
lower footprint and
we had this ability to now
handle hard deletes to be able to
provide full visibility
into all the changes to a given row or a
given
set of rows in the destination if
there was a need for that so we said
about building
a cdc connector for these databases so
this is also
uh just about the time that uh postgres
uh specifically on aws came out
with uh logical decoding right so you
that was also not something like
these right ahead logs are written for
the consumption
by the same database right not by anyone
else
because it was meant for replication my
sequel was much better it had been logs
that
in fact back in facebook over 10 years
ago we were
kind of talking about and we had built
systems to read the bin logs
and we were already doing those kinds of
things uh back then
but uh with postness logical decoding
was kind of something new and we we set
about building
a cdc connector because uh we had this
end-to-end flow so when you think about
what it means to build cdc a cdc
connector
turns out it's actually more complicated
than any other data integration that you
would have to build
you need the in-just capability you need
the transform capability
because you're just getting the changes
and then you're applying the changes
onto the destination so
you need the transform capability as
well so because we had those primitives
we set about building the cdc connectors
and then we started finding that you can
provide more guarantees you can in fact
provide much more robust data freshness
guarantees
you can provide uh
see uh checksum based uh kind of uh
guarantees to say that the data was
actually replicated with high fidelity
so that is when we got really excited
about cdc
and uh so our question was okay why is
it not possible for all data
integrations to be cdc
right and that's the reason i kind of
wrote that post
in uh towards data science um so
as we kind of looked at what it means to
build cdc clearly
uh production databases that have been
around are much more amenable
to cdc because they write out this uh
right ahead log
that can be read but other systems uh
whether they're apis or uh even file
systems so it's actually
a hard thing to kind of build right now
but we believe that cdc uh
raises the bar uh uh or what a data
integration
cannon could be doing
i just um published i i posted that blog
post in the
youtube chat so that folks can find it
in case they're watching a replay of
this and don't see the chat
the the title of the post is all data
integration should use
change data capture by ragu from april
2021 it's on towards data science on
medium
um well that that's fascinating raghu
and it sort of makes sense that when
you're talking about
um sort of the the other benefits you
get
from having a fully cdc compliant system
um in terms of data freshness and it
sort of can improve your slas
in other ways i guess that's an
interesting
maybe sort of un unexpected side effect
of this process that you discovered yeah
so
the more we dug into building really
robust cdc connectors
we realized that
clearly there are kind of specialized
cdc
uh players uh in the market
uh but in terms of data integrations our
thinking was that
we uh like there are already some
products that offer you know they don't
really call it cdc but they offer this
whole event-based
uh kind of approach to kind of fetching
data like stripe is a great example
where they have apis where you can fetch
the individual objects
like invoices and whatever else
but they also have an api for events
so that allows us
and so we read those events so these
events
are generated every time any object is
changed
so this starts looking a lot more like a
right ahead log in a database
right so we have been able to uh
kind of leverage that in stripe we
are also kind of hoping that any of all
of these uh
other tools that provide apis to fetch
or access data in bulk
if they start offering these uh kind of
event streams
instead then it makes
building a cdc connector a lot easier
to get easier it actually makes building
a cdc connector possible
we have a question from daniel um
about this i think it's about metadata
in the cdc context um raghu let me let
me read this to you
and um and see what your thoughts are
he's asking
can you talk about the metadata layer in
this context
query queue proc accesses table a
at noon then it accesses table b
at 1 1pm which accesses
a at 1 pm which had been updated
that's a bit of a it's a bit of a puzzle
do you understand where daniel is going
with that
um i'm guessing
uh so let me tell you what i
uh understand understand from the
question and maybe
i need to clarify where cdc is happening
right and where the transformations are
happening so
when you talk about queries that are
running at different points in time
from our kind of point of view or from
like what we see is transformations that
are
running in the destination warehouse and
that is the
what we orchestrate and drive so
when uh when we are doing cdc
uh we are actually batching up the
changes
that are coming in before we load that
into the destination warehouse
we are not doing like row by row updates
of the destination warehouse 2 because
that would just be really inefficient
because data warehouses are not really
meant to be doing kind of
uh in place updates of like individual
rows right so
we actually uh perform batch
operations in the destination
right which is the warehouse now when we
talk about
the event stream or like the right ahead
log that's coming in
it has all the information right so it
has all the changes that have happened
uh since the last time we fetched our
we actually fetch it in a stream so we
keep fetching it and we kind of
cut these batches that then get
applied to all the tables in the
destination so there is a single stream
that is coming in with changes from all
the tables in the source
because that's how right head logs
work and that's also like a
lower footprint way of building a cdc
connector you can actually have
separate writer logs that you can read
from for each of the tables and that
just
adds more load to the to the source
database
so what we do is there's a single stream
that is coming in
with changes from all the tables we cut
that into these batch micro batches so
it could be every minute or five minutes
or whatever depending on what the
customer's requirements are
and then we apply the changes to the
destination tables in batches
once that happens we have uh
the use case is still analytics right we
are not building streaming systems here
uh in data coral we have
converted the streaming kind of uh
system
into a batch micro batch oriented
kind of flow and the metadata
i'm trying to answer the question that
came in the metadata
is about these small batches of data
that are getting updated into the
destination tables and that drives
orchestration
right so the our orchestration is of
course
also driving the updates to the table so
there's one
kind of process or one container that's
kind of reading all of these
the stream of data and cutting into two
batches ones that have
each batch generates an event that then
triggers the transformation
that then triggers orchestration which
will then kind of do
the rest of this the data flow for that
batch of data
so a query that runs at a different
point in time
the uh
actually has all the changes until that
point in time
the one of the nuance here and
this can get into a lot of depth
is that these batches are
of data that are coming in are mostly
arrival time based
so the idea is that when you have a
streaming system
the most robust way of ingesting that
streaming data
is to just uh and convert into batches
is
to create batches based on arrival time
and then you apply these batches to the
destination tables
which is also kind of arrival time and
then at some point you have to decide
that all the data for a particular day
is done
right this is kind of like closer books
or high water mark or things like that
that
people are people are going to talk
about we have incorporated that into our
orchestration too
so we know based on the metadata
of each batch what is the timestamp in
that latest timestamp in that batch
and when that timestamp crosses the high
watermark
we know that all data for a particular
time period has been
collected which then drives something
downstream
and from that point onwards the batching
as such
is more data time based rather than
arrival time based
got it hopefully that made sense i will
also kind of write about it
uh yeah i i i think so um daniel just
wanted to clarify that he's talking
about a fairly common
race condition and so it seems to me
like based on this batching
the the time windows of the batching
that you articulated raghu um
you know if if the query happens sort of
after the
the cdc batches come in then everything
would be fine if the query is sort of
you know happening before the the micro
matches come in then
then perhaps it wouldn't be caught but
it seems to be it's sort of about the
the amount of time in this windowing um
that the cgc batches come in if that
makes sense yeah actually that
problem that daniel talked about is
literally solved by our data driven
orchestration
if you write that query as a
transformation that is within our system
it is orchestrated automatically so what
that means
is that the query will not run until
that batch has
been applied to the table right see
that's the
beauty of having this event driven
orchestration
right this is how the event driven
orchestration and the cdc actually
worked together
i knew there was some connection
somewhere that we were going to uncover
yeah yeah so the uh the metadata driven
orchestration or like the metadata first
architecture
meant that it was going to be data
during orchestration
and that is the primitive that we have
used to build the cdc connectors
so it naturally kind of solves the
problem
of being able to write these
transformations or these queries that
you can then register within our kind of
metadata and
our orchestration kind of picks that up
from our metadata
that query doesn't even run until the
batch has been applied
got it yeah that makes sense
um so so moving on raghu
um i just wanted to ask you like
what are some of the pitfalls of folks
trying to roll their own
cdc implementations right there's
there's some open source tools out there
there's the bcm which
i'm starting to hear a little bit more
about these days um do you see companies
have success
in trying to implement these these
things on their own or what sort of
advice would you would you give folks
who are
um thinking about going one way or the
other
yes so we talked about the advantages of
cdc
right so if those advantages actually
make sense
and people actually want it at this
point in time they'll have to bear the
cost so to speak
of putting together a cdc solution
our goal within data coral and or i
think
what is going to happen even in the
industry overall is it's the barrier to
entry for cdc will lower
quite a bit and then
i probably in a couple years or whatever
like people won't even know about
uh the complexities of cvc because a lot
of systems would have already kind of
simplified how cdc works
so now uh companies have a few options
right so
there are uh pretty sophisticated cdc
solutions
tend to be expensive they've been around
for a while uh you can kind of go for
that
uh or you can go for these kind of open
source
tools like the bzm that do take up some
engineering to set up
and also keep keep it working
there are other tools that are other
data integration providers that also
offer
cdc capabilities but they have the
if they are sas then of course they have
the uh
the property that data is flowing
through their systems before kind of
coming back to your warehouse
you may or may not kind of want that
um and of course i have also uh
mentioned data coral because we have uh
built uh
our own kind of cdc connector as well
it does so nowadays
what we are hearing people say is that
they would like cdc
they think it's like any other data
integration but once they start getting
into it
they feel like it's a deceptively hard
problem to solve
so we have been working pretty hard to
make that easier
people shouldn't really have to worry
about all of the underlying
kind of moving parts to uh get like the
robust cdc solution and i think the
industry overall
will also kind of make that happen
great yeah that makes sense um
hopefully some of the complexity will be
abstracted away by
tooling um you know smartly designed
systems like data coral and others
as you've mentioned and folks can start
to capture the value of this in their
own systems
without hiring an army of of data
engineers
um which we talked about earlier um so
so ragu as we wrap up i just wanted to
ask you
you've spent so much time in the data
ecosystem
are there any particular areas of data
that you're excited about
on the infrastructure level that you
sort of see
emerging or consolidating or
people talking about i'm just curious as
to like what's on the horizon for you
and
what you're excited to track going
forward
yeah so i think we covered a couple of
things at least that i'm excited about
we are talking more about it we are
seeing that there is a lot of
conversations in the industry as well
one is the metadata first
architecture which
we believe reduces the complexity of
building a data stack uh we've written a
little bit about that as well
so i think there'll be more that will
happen in that area
and of course the second one is cdc uh
to become the norm for all data
integrations rather than
just the specialized kind of the
database integrations if you will
so i think these are the two uh thing
or two threads that we'll keep kind of
uh uh
pulling on with that's what is kind of
exciting for us
uh as well as we are kind of building on
it and
i'm also seeing that in the industry
there are uh
there was this kind of phase where um
there were multiple tools so there's
always
like a consolidation phase that happens
and there is this
expansion phase where people end up
building specialized
kind of solutions for each part of
whatever functionality that they want
then they realize that oh there are now
too many moving parts and
there is a split brain problem there
there's
metadata that's kind of split across
multiple tools so now we need to
consolidate
so i believe that in the next few years
we'll start seeing more of this
consolidation
happening where companies just don't
want to
kind of deal with multiple tools and or
not
deal multiple tools even though there
are multiple tools they want those tools
to play nice with each other
and how we are thinking about it is
they should all have this the same
shared metadata
so i think that is
where the industry will move it people
want more consolidation now
earlier it was about kind of breaking
off from these central tools like
informatica
and building just being just or
jeffrey's
[Music]
so we'll get into this hybrid where
there'll be like a common uh metadata
layer but then there'll be
scope for multiple tools to come in and
do their kind of best
on their part of the their functionality
but then the metadata layer is the same
so management becomes easier
yeah but still be part of a unified
system um through the metadata layer
yeah awesome well um yeah you're
reinforcing great things that we've
talked about here
on dc thursdays um as well so it's great
to great to hear that we're on the right
track
and we really appreciate you sharing
your experience with us today roku um
it's been great to catch up as always
um i always enjoy our conversations and
i learn a lot from from listening to you
so thanks for all your investment in the
the data community
so far where can people find you if they
want more information
about data coral or if they want to ask
you questions about other advanced
architectures that
they might the they might want to pick
your brain on
yeah so you can learn more about data
coil at
datacore.com and you can reach me at
ragu datacore.co and uh yeah
thank you so much for having me here
i've always enjoyed our conversations
and uh yeah i hope this was useful as
well
yeah yeah thank you it's been super
useful for the community um
and i look forward to seeing you in
person soon thanks
okay uh so for
for listeners i just wanted to mention
that we have
several more episodes already lined up
for dc thursday
next thursday on may 20th please join us
for a talk with
boris jabez from census
on operational analytics um raghu and i
briefly touched on the reverse etl
category today and so
um boris is the the co-founder of census
and we'll have some interesting things
to say on that topic
also don't forget to subscribe to the
the data council channel
um hit the bell icon so that you get
notifications when we go live next time
and don't forget you can also find all
the previous dc thursdays in our
playlist
right here on youtube so thanks everyone
look forward to